what you're about to watch is a
refurbishing of an old video but even if
you've seen that old video I'd encourage
you to stick around the whole reason I
wanted to go back and clean up some of
the mistakes and reshape a bit of the
story line is that it's a really nice
piece of math the kind that deserves to
be preserved and it's best light if it's
going to be presented in a video that
exists in perpetuity plus math is deep
so there is almost always something new
to be gained from a second or a third
look at the topic you know that feeling
you get when things that seem completely
unrelated turn out to have a key
connection in math especially there's a
certain tingly sensation I get whenever
one of those connections starts to fall
into place this is what I have in store
for you today it takes some time to set
up I have to introduce a fair division
puzzle from discrete math called the
stolen necklace problem as well as a
topological fact about spheres that
we'll use to solve it called the borsa
Coulomb theorem but trust me seeing
these two seemingly disconnected pieces
of math come together is well worth the
set up let's start with the puzzle that
we're going to solve you and your friend
steal a necklace full of a whole bunch
of jewels maybe it's got some sapphires
emeralds diamonds and rubies they're all
arranged on the necklace in some random
order and let's say that it happens to
be an even number of each type of jewel
right here I have eight sapphires ten
emeralds for diamonds and six rubies you
and your friend want to split up the
booty evenly with each of you getting
half of each jewel type that is four
sapphires five emeralds two diamonds and
three rubies each of course you could
just cut off all of the jewels and divvy
them up evenly but that's boring there's
not a puzzle there instead the challenge
is for you to make as few cuts to the
necklace as possible so that you can
divvy up the resulting segments between
you and your co-conspirator with each of
you getting half of each jewel type for
example for the arrangement that I'm
showing here I just did it with four
cuts if I give the top three strands to
you and these bottom two strands to your
co-conspirator each of you ends up with
four sapphires five emeralds
two diamonds and three rubies the claim
the thing that I want to prove in this
video is that if there are n different
jewel types it's always possible to do
this fair division with only n cuts or
fewer so with four jewel types in this
example no matter what random ordering
of the jewels it should be possible to
cut it in four places and divvy up the
five necklace pieces so that each thief
has the same number of each jewel type
with 5 jul 2015 15 and allocating some
collections of things in a balanced way
these are the kind of optimization
issues that actually come up quite
frequently in practical applications for
the computer system folks among you I'm
sure you can imagine how this is
analogous to kinds of efficient memory
allocation problems also for the curious
among you I've left a link in the
description to an electrical engineering
paper that applies this specific problem
independent from the usefulness though
it certainly does make for a good puzzle
can you always find a fair division
using only as many cuts as there are
types of jewels
so that's the puzzle remember it and now
we take a seemingly unrelated sidestep
to the total opposite side of the
mathematical universe
topology imagine taking a sphere in 3d
space and squishing it somehow on to the
2d plane
stretching and morphing it however you'd
like to do so the only constraint I'll
ask is that you do this continuously
which you can think of as meaning never
cut the sphere or tear it in any way
during this mapping
as you do this many different pairs of
points will land on top of each other
once they hit the plane and you know
that's not really a big deal the special
fact that we're going to use known as
the Borsig Coulomb theorem is that you
will always be able to find a pair of
points that started off on the exact
opposite sides of the sphere which land
on each other during the mapping points
on the exact opposite like this are
called Antipodes or antipodal points for
example if you think of the sphere as
Earth and your mapping is a straight
projection of every point directly onto
the plane of the equator the North and
the South Pole which are antipodal each
land on the same point and in this
example that's the only antipodal pair
that lands on the same point and and the
other antipodal pair will end up offset
from each other somehow
if you tweaked this function a bit maybe
shearing it during the projection the
northern the South Pole they don't land
on each other anymore but when the
topology gods close a door they open a
window because the Borsig Coulomb
theorem guarantees that no matter what
there must be some other and typical
pair that now land on top of each other
the classic example to illustrate this
idea which math educators introducing
borsa Coulomb are required by law to
present is that there must exist some
pair of points on the opposite side of
the earth where the temperature and the
barometric pressure are both precisely
the same this is because associating
each point on the surface of the earth
with a pair of numbers temperature and
pressure is the same thing as mapping
the surface of the earth onto a 2d
coordinate plane where the first
coordinate represents temperature and
the second represents pressure the
implicit assumption here is that
temperature and pressure each vary
continuously as you walk around the
earth so this association is a
continuous mapping from the sphere onto
a plane some non tearing way to squish
that surface into two dimensions
so what bore so Coulomb implies is that
no matter what the weather patterns on
earth or any other planet for that
matter to antipodal points must land on
top of each other which means they map
to the same temperature pressure pair
since you're watching this video you're
probably a mathematician at heart
so you want to see why this is true not
just that it's true so let's take a
little side step through topology proof
land and I think you'll agree that this
is a really satisfying line of reasoning
first rephrasing what it is we want to
show slightly more symbolically if you
have some function f that takes in a
point P of the sphere and spits out some
pair of coordinates you want to show
that no matter what crazy choice of
function this is as long as it's
continuous you'll be able to find some
point P so that F of P equals F of
negative P where negative P is the
antipodal point on the other side of the
sphere the key idea here which might
seem small at first is to rearrange this
and say f of P minus F of negative P
equals zero zero and focus on a new
function G of P that's defined to be
this left-hand side here F of P minus F
of negative P this way what we need to
show is that G Maps some point of the
sphere on to the origin in 2d space so
rather than finding a pair of colliding
points which could land anywhere this
helps limit our focus to just one point
of the output space the origin
this function G has a pretty special
property which is going to help us out
that G of negative P is equal to
negative G of P basically negating the
input involves swapping these terms in
other words going to the antipodal point
of the sphere results in reflecting the
output of G through the origin of the
output space or maybe think of it as
rotating that output 180 degrees around
the origin notice what this means if you
were to continuously walk around the
equator and look at the outputs of G
what happens when you go half way around
[Music]
well the output needs to have wandered
to the reflection of the starting point
through the origin then as you continue
walking around the other half the second
half of your output path must be the
reflection of the first half or
equivalently it's the 180-degree
rotation of that first path now there's
a slim possibility that one of these
points happens to pass through the
origin in which case you've lucked out
and we're done early but otherwise what
we have here is a path that winds around
the origin at least once and now look at
that path on the equator and imagine
continuously deforming it up to the
North Pole cinching that loop tight as
you do this the resulting path in the
output space is also continuously
deforming to a point since the function
G is continuous now because it wound
around the origin at some point during
this process it must cross the origin
and this means there is some point P on
the sphere where G of P has the
coordinates 0 0
which means F of P minus F of negative P
equals zero zero meaning F of P is the
same as f of negative P the antipodal
collision that we're looking for isn't
that clever and it's a pretty common
style of argument in the context of
topology it doesn't matter what
particular continuous function from the
sphere to the plane you define this line
of reasoning will always zero in on an
end typical pair that lands on top of
each other at this point maybe you're
thinking yeah yeah lovely math and all
but we've strayed pretty far away from
the necklace problem but just you wait
here's where things start getting clever
first answer me this what is a sphere
really well points in 3d space are
represented with three coordinates in
some sense that's what 3d space is to a
mathematician at least all possible
Triplets of numbers and the simplest
sphere to describe with coordinates is
the standard unit sphere centered at the
origin the set of all points a distance
1 from the origin meaning all Triplets
of numbers so that the sum of their
squares is 1 so the geometric idea of a
sphere is related to the algebraic idea
of a set of positive numbers that add up
to 1 that might sound simple but tuck
that away in your mind if you have one
of these triplets the point on the
opposite side of the sphere the
corresponding antipodal point is
whatever you get by flipping the sign of
each coordinate right so let's just
write out what the Borsig coulomb
theorem is saying symbolically trust me
this will help with getting back to the
necklace problem for any function that
takes in points on the sphere Triplets
of numbers who square some to 1 and
spits out some point in 2d space some
pair of coordinates like temperature and
pressure as long as the function is
continuous there will be some input so
that flipping all of its signs doesn't
change the output with that in mind look
back at the necklace problem part of the
reason these two things feel so very
unrelated is that the necklace problem
is discrete while the Borsig coulomb
theorem is continuous so our first step
is to translate the stolen necklace
problem into a continuous version
seeking the connection between necklace
divisions and points on the sphere
for right now let's limit ourself to the
case where there's only two jewels say
sapphires and emeralds and we're hoping
to make a fair division of this necklace
after only two cuts as an example just
to have up on the screen let's say
there's eight sapphires and ten emeralds
on the necklace just as a reminder this
means the goal is to cut the necklace in
two different spots and divvy up those
three segments so that each thief ends
up with half of the sapphires and half
of the emeralds notice the top and the
bottom each have four sapphires and five
emeralds for our continuous if ocation
think of the necklace as a line with
length one with the jewels sitting
evenly spaced on it and divided up that
line into 18 evenly sized segments one
for each jewel and rather than thinking
of each jewel as a discrete indivisible
entity on each segment remove the jewel
itself and just paint that segment the
color of the jewel so in this case 8/18
of the wine would be painted sapphire
and ten eighteenth's would be painted
emerald the continuous variant of the
puzzle is now to ask if we can find two
cuts anywhere on this line not
necessarily on the 118th interval marks
that lets us divide up the pieces so
that each thief has an equal length of
each color in this case each thief
should have a total of 4/18 of sapphire
colored segments and five eighteenth's
of emerald colored segments and
important but somewhat subtle point here
is that if you can solve the continuous
variant you can also solve the original
discrete version to see this let's say
you did find a fair division whose cuts
didn't happen to fall cleanly between
the jewels maybe it cuts only partway
through an emerald segment well because
this is a fair division the length of
emerald in both top and bottom has to
add up to five total emerald segments a
whole number multiple of the segment
lengths so even if the division cut
partially into an emerald segment on the
left it has to cut partially into an
emerald segment on the right and more
specifically in such a way that the
total length adds up to a whole number
multiple of the segment lengths
what that means is that you can adjust
each cut without affecting the division
so that they ultimately do line up on
the 118th marks now why are we doing all
this well in the continuous case where
you can cut wherever you want on this
line think about all of the choices
going into dividing the necklace and
allocating the pieces first you choose
two locations to cut the interval but
another way to think about that is to
choose three positive numbers that add
up to one for example maybe you choose
1/6 1/3 and 1/2 which correspond to
these two cuts anytime you find three
positive numbers that add up to one it
gives you a way to cut the necklace and
vice versa after that you have to make a
binary choice for each of these pieces
for whether it goes to theif 1 or thief
2 now compare that to if I asked you to
choose some arbitrary point on a sphere
in 3-dimensional space some point with
coordinates X Y Z so that x squared plus
y squared plus Z squared equals 1 well
you might start off by choosing 3
positive numbers that add to 1 maybe you
want x squared to be 1/6 Y squared to be
1/3 and Z squared to be 1/2 then you
have to make a binary choice for each
one of them choosing whether to take the
positive square root or the negative
square root in a way that's completely
parallel to dividing the necklace and
allocating the pieces
all right hang with me now because this
is the key observation of the whole
video it gives the correspondence
between points on the sphere and
necklace divisions for any point X Y Z
on the sphere because x squared plus y
squared plus Z squared is 1 you can cut
the necklace so that the first piece has
a length x squared the second has a
length Y squared and the third has a
length Z squared for that first piece if
X is positive give it to theif 1
otherwise give it to thief 2 for the
second piece if Y is positive give it to
theif 1 otherwise give it to thief 2 and
likewise give the third piece to thief 1
if Z is positive and - thief - if Z is
negative and you could go the other way
around
any way that you divide up the necklace
and divvy up the pieces gives us a
unique point on the sphere it's as if
the sphere is a weirdly perfect way to
encapsulate the idea of all possible
necklace divisions just with a geometric
object and here we are tantalisingly
close think of the meaning of antipodal
points under this Association if the
point XYZ on the sphere corresponds to
some necklace allocation what is the
point negative x negative Y and negative
Z correspond to well the squares of
these three coordinates are the same so
each one corresponds to making the same
cuts on the necklace the difference is
that every piece switches which theif it
belongs to so jumping to an end typical
point on the opposite side of the sphere
corresponds with exchanging the pieces
now remember what it is that we're
actually looking for we want the total
length of each of jewel type belonging
to thief 1 to equal that for thief 2 or
in other words in a fair division
performing this antipodal swap doesn't
change the amount of each jewel
belonging to each thief your brain
should be burning with the thought of
borsa Coulomb at this point specifically
you might construct a function that
takes in a given necklace allocation and
spits out two numbers the total length
of sapphire belonging to thief 1 and the
total length of emerald belonging to
thief 1 we want to show that there must
exist a way to divide the necklace with
two cuts and divvy up the pieces so that
these two numbers are the same as what
they would be for
- for said differently we're swapping
all of the pieces wouldn't change those
two numbers because of this back and
forth between necklace allocations and
the points of the sphere and because
pairs of numbers correspond with points
on the XY plane this is in effect a map
from the sphere on to the plane and the
animation you're looking at right now is
that literal map for the necklace I was
showing so the Borsig alum theorem
guarantees that some antipodal pair of
points on the sphere land on each other
in the plane which means there must be
some necklace division using two cuts
that gives a fair division between the
thieves that my friends is what
beautiful math feels like all right and
if you're anything like me you're just
basking in the glow of what a clever
proof that is and it might be easy to
forget that what we actually want to
solve is the more general stole a
necklace problem with any number of
jewel types luckily we've now done 95%
of the work
generalizing is pretty brief the main
thing to mention is that there is a more
general version of the borsa coulomb
theorem one that applies to higher
dimensional spheres as an example for so
Coulomb applies to mapping hyper spheres
in 40 space into three dimensions and
what I mean by a hyper sphere is the set
of all possible lists of four
coordinates where the sum of their
squares equals one those are the points
in 40 space a distance 1 from the origin
for Saku LOM says that if you try to map
that set all those special quadruplets
of numbers into three-dimensional space
continuously associating each one with
some triplet of numbers there must be
some antipodal collision an input X 1 X
2 X 3 X 4 we're flipping all of the
signs wouldn't change the output I'll
leave it to you to pause and ponder and
think about how this could apply to the
three dual case and about what the
general statement of course Aquila might
be and how it applies to the general
necklace problem
and maybe just maybe this gives you an
inkling of why mathematicians care about
things like higher dimensional spheres
regardless of whether or not they exist
in physical reality it's not always
about the sphere per se it's about what
other problems in math they can be used
to encode
[Music]
you